do you guys want to watch any like like
horror youtubers
they find horror youtubers like talk
about horror like corpse husband and
stuff like that
yeah not really cop subscribe i mean he
used to do
like creepy pasta stuff right i guess so
yeah yeah this crew passed it like this
oh i missed the creepypasta and stuff
like that
i don't watch mr creepy faster i met him
in real life oh really
yeah how was he flawed
hopefully he didn't watch this
i mean i i feel like it takes a quirky
personality right yeah
he was nice but you know odd by my
british i mean casey
most americans are odd i'm trying to
save this now
you were very pleasant but i guess you
were a little bit off right
wait don't we have an entire clip of
that which is like americans or
different species oh yeah we have
yeah yeah we do check out exactly
there's uh obviously rainbot who did the
mr anime videos oh that one uh next
unexpected cameo in that one yeah oh
yeah there's a
next photo some pretty good ones as well
i really like his video a redditor's
dive into turmoil that's really good
have you seen that no that's about where
the woman who
uh asked a subreddit for help a man has
to help the subreddit to get custody of
the kids
and then the wife killed them both when
she saw the subreddit um
yikes and it's just a really i know that
story i've showed you
yeah i've showed you it's a really like
you just didn't expect the video to go
that way yeah really just chilling video
and uh i highly recommend i mean we
spoiled it i recommend it i mean we all
know the best horror
channel is uh chills my boy chill oh god
the greatest
burger king foot lettuce i can't tell
you how [ __ ] happy i was that i was
in one of these videos yeah yeah
he said my name i was like i've made it
as a youtuber like that's
it's peak have you seen the video where
he just talks he's such a genuine and
nice guy as well
like chills yeah because like that's
just how he talks right yeah that's how
he talks
because everybody thinks he's like
purposely trying to make this like
annoying accent but like
i've seen videos where he just like
talks off script that's just how he
talks just want to give him a high five
yeah he's so nice dude chills i [ __ ]
love you like come on please come on to
the podcast it would be the most
amazing sounding podcast uh also a guy
who popped up not too long ago uh badly
sociable he does really good videos he
did a really good video on
the silk road as well oh i might have
seen what's the silk road
uh it was the website that was famous on
the deep web for selling drugs
and i thought it was some like
mastermind criminal or organization but
it turned out it was just some dudes
like petty infighting about getting
yeah i feel like i've seen a lot of
these guys content on like my
recommended probably watched it
it's it's because like it's it's not the
type of content i would subscribe to
right like if it's an interesting enough
topic i'm willing to [ __ ] click on
anything in my recommended